this VW scandal is not just about money  it's also about health as well and  cheating the standards brings a massive  and fundamental breach of trust what  happened is completely unacceptable we  expect full investigation and full  accountability of those who are  responsible we must start by  establishing the facts you asked me how  the Commission will investigate any  potential wrongdoing the Commission does  not have the power to carry our own  investigation in the automotive sector  we rely rely on the authorities of the  member states these institutions are  professional let's not jeopardize what  we have built together so far own an  affair ananta mobility Velma Dinkley  mervyn least open the Moose Nina burst  open damn it under the kinder Darren  kinder and perspective arm of discipline  in sooo lame